are you seeing a lot of other girls at
the same time when i was with that
girlfriend this one that you're seeing
at the moment the one i'm just saying
don't say that i'm not saying that
but your feedback
21 times yesterday
[Laughter]
but it's only toxic if he gets caught
why is it toxic in a relationship if the
girls don't know about it because she's
not my girlfriend
there you go to be fair she's not his
girl
she's selling herself a dream you're
saying that she knows fully that where
she stands i broke up with her yes we're
not together no way that you're getting
back together she knows that she left
the country because of the situation to
go and get a land right came back and
still messaging me about i don't know
why you made a girl leave the country
yeah you've got a toxic schlong yeah
you said you wanted his number in the
beginning of the show so this is like
the red this is the red flag
relationship
you guys can like you guys can be like
the toxic
she saw the gold the titans
oh here we go
[Laughter]
some people find love on this show i
don't know i don't know trust me i know
that i get bad dms asking about girls
after the show i've been decommissioned
i don't live like that no more because
it wasn't making me happy okay well
anyways
yeah yeah so
have you been in a toxic relationship um
that means yes when you have to say um
confess
i won't really say toxic toxic it was
just more of a narcissism that was
that's basically where
um she felt that
what i tell her that she's doing wrong
isn't wrong
so yeah that's toxic
and she comes up with ways to defend her
actions and
so no kind of manipulation manipulation
yeah
yeah that's that's quite that's quite
bad
because it's like it's always your fault
right yeah yeah
when they say something it's like oh
you're being crazy you're being crazy
gaslighting no not really like that she
just comes up with ways in which
um maybe something something's happening
and i'm saying that no you shouldn't do
that and she's like no it's a good idea
to do this and she comes up with ways to
say that that idea is not bad
relationships
you don't respect so i'm manipulating
we're going to say toxic yeah yeah okay
so anyways the winner of the red flag
contest
how do you feel i feel good you feel
toxic
because i was in so much pain back then
so i'm so proud of the woman i am today
oh my god i'm scared
how much girls that have come on here
and admitted that they would have lied
and been like oh i i don't know
there's women out here watching me who
have had seven abortions you have a
cemetery for a stomach do not judge me
you know what's interesting though you
know what's interesting and i can just
kind of see the men versus women dynamic
is like like you when um she was talking
were defending her but when michael was
talking you're like ooh that's kind of
bad but they even though i feel about my
girl
no even if she's making bad decisions
you don't know her 21 like dude
this dude was a whole different person
like a few months ago i just like i mean
i've been 20 i've been 21 before but
like i can't imagine ever like sleeping
with a sugar daddy when you're married
like when you have a child i wasn't
married though
yeah but like i just think that's why
you get the
you have a baby isn't that worse like a
baby mom like it was technically he was
someone else that wasn't the person
that's like the relationship see okay
i'm gonna give you another red flag
because now because because because you
keep getting excuses i'm not giving
excuses
yeah yeah but the thing is like like
it's one thing to say okay i did that it
was [ __ ] up and i shouldn't have did
it no right but when you're you're like
saying oh well i was young
it's like it's like when you say i'm
sorry but it's like when you give an
excuse it kind of
it kind of takes away the accountability
a lot so
it was wrong
you know what though i do appreciate the
honesty because it does take a lot to
admit something like that
don't mean you're going to get a black
friday should we should we take away red
flag for honesty
i have never done anything like that and
then i guess we've got to take one for
you because you've been honest too so
i'm saying like yeah yeah
so really
yeah because you've said a lot of
madness
i wasn't married to him it's okay i
wasn't he's not he was not my husband
you've also got to remember you only had
you only had like three or four red
flags from the incident and then
everything you said after is what got
you the rest of them no i think there's
just super judgment going on because i
told you what i did oh of course there's
judgment going on but i said what i did
so why are we getting extra flags i've
told you what i did yeah but you are
defending yeah you're not defending the
flag
you are rationalizing your actions yeah
it was messed up okay but
i'm just saying i'm giving i'm making
assumptions based on the information you
gave me yeah i cheated on him
and i i did the same thing to michael he
got red flags too
if you don't just keep quiet
he just
can you add one add it back
[Laughter]
you need to get red flag merch like a
red flag hat or like a big red t-shirt
and you're going to wear that for the
rest of the show
just so you know to stay away
but a lot of people are doing stuff like
this and they're lying about it no it's
true
that i'm married their husband is away
on work and they are sleeping around oh
yeah i don't know men that are doing the
same so at the end i wasn't married to
him i wasn't married i don't think
that's the baby okay okay get married
you need to get a ready teacher
one at a time um
yeah but it's how is it better
how is it better just because you
weren't married you had a kid so you may
as well be married no that's generous
that's it
okay that's it
honestly that's a bigger commitment like
i can't meet today i could i could get
married to a guy tomorrow yeah and then
be divorced never talk to him again if
you're a kid with someone you you're
stuck with them for life true yeah well
he was not my husband i did not vow
to commit my life to him at that point
together together we were on and off
at that point i didn't value the
relationship the wealth being treated
yeah you should have stepped up okay
but why is there always an excuse like
this is this is the thing about all of
these things led to that it's not it's
not good that i did it right it's not
good but it's the only thing i'm
pointing out is like this is the
difference between men versus women is
women are allowed to make excuses for
their bad behavior that was terrible no
no no and you keep arguing with it
because because because when you're when
michael when michael was judged in the
same room with you the same thing
happened to him we judged michael ten
red flags and and
and and and michael just took it but
you're like arguing with it i am arguing
with it when you're saying like like
but it's like it's the same behavior it
was bad it was bad straight up true you
didn't make anything thank you
appreciate it
i appreciate you appreciating the skills
that some men do make excuses as well
but you didn't he didn't he didn't no i
think i think some men do but in general
most don't and i do i know this because
i i talk to people four days a week no i
mean
and even on even on
even on tick tock when um i talk about
men versus women cheating whenever it's
about woman cheating it's always well
why did she cheat
because men are men are supposed to
protect and provide women
but
women okay i don't know your situation
but i'm talking about cheating and
you're changing the subject
and you asked you asked you stop
interrupting stop interrupting me when
we're talking about cheating okay that's
what we're talking about men's duty is
to protect and provide women are
supposed to be loyal
and so
and so if you're not loyal that's you're
going against what you're supposed to do
i was loyal but i wasn't faithful
it's not it's not it's not it's not
loyal but it's different between loyalty
and faithful no it's not loyal you
weren't loyal like like think about this
okay okay i can't i'm just thinking i'm
just thinking about this for my mom and
dad and i'm thinking of my mother like
said to me oh i was faithful all right i
was loyal i wasn't faithful
i was like what are you talking about
like is that what you teach your
daughter no
between being loyal and being faithful
okay tell me the difference between
being loyal is you are there
no matter what throughout which i was
until the relationship ended but in
being faithful i wasn't being true
that is the difference i i think you're
just making up words
but if they're the same thing if loyalty
and faithfulness are the same thing
right why are they two different i think
for
for women loyalty for women for women
for women loyalty is being sexually
exclusive
because
historically men had to ensure paternity
for men loyalty is giving us their
resources
and so that's why you got more red flags
than michael did
for cheating because you're not doing
what a woman's supposed to do fair
enough
do you think do you think with him
knowing that's me like 15 years ago do
you think with him knowing he would call
you loyal
yes
yeah no i know what i did for him and he
knows what i did for him so he held the
strap
oh he was a good guy actually so you
wouldn't have done that yeah no i i i
held it down for him yeah yes i'm saying
that with my whole chest i made a
mistake and i did own up to it and you
enjoyed it
let's not go to these questions
let's just move forward i found jesus
christ
when did you find jesus around 30 20.
last sunday late 20s late 20s like it
was between like 28 to 33. i was 20.
seven six when 2016
epiphany
that's a rainbow moment no women women
tend to find jesus when they need a
husband and time's running out
i didn't want to get married when i
found him but i'm glad i did because it
made me realize how messed up a lot of
the decisions i was making do you think
the church keeps the women women single
just yes to some degree and then to some
degree no why well i asked a man
recently why is it there's more women in
church than men and he said um
if men see bs
and spot it they're not going to stick
around whereas women will be led
they'll be convinced but um i think if i
think to be honest church there's a lot
of feminism seeping into the church and
we're not aware of it like we're
like we like you said women do blindly
support each other and i think
we do blindly support each other and
sometimes me too you need to just be
like
sis you're moving mad you need to cut
that out yeah and i think if we don't
have that
that is that is a dangerous thing with
each other because if you like women
don't like to be corrected like i was
arguing just a minute ago what i did was
messed up
modern women
don't want to admit that and even
like especially becoming a christian
actually taking it seriously i realized
so much of the things i was doing was
just me
acting out of pain and not wanting to
take accountability
like i do think so to me like i think a
lot of the problem in the church is they
always give women excuses and bailouts
and so you can so you can say i would
like
and i hate doing this but this is like a
perfect example because what they'll do
is they'll like victimize women and
they'll say oh i was so broken i was in
such a bad head space i was so this i
didn't have jesus
and then
like they can come back and say oh i got
baptized and now i'm a good woman and
it's like but to be honest with you in
in when i first gave my life to christ
i was like that yeah but the more i
pressed into actually reading the bible
and actually allowing the holy spirit to
work on me i realized
there's so much things that had to come
out well and and
it may be genuine for you but i'm not
the same person anymore this like for me
now
i don't have sex
because at the end of the day my main
thing is i do not want to agree with the
holy spirit if you're having sex outside
of marriage
god created marriage for a safe space
for women to have sex and pleasure he
does want you how many how many kids do
you have i have one we have one do you
think that keeps you single though
because why would a guy wait to marry
you if you he you gave someone else a
kid well the man that god has for me
will wait no but that's the thing no no
he won't because then i guess if if i
die single i'd rather die single and
please the lord you're never going to go
and sleep around in the hopes of maybe
getting a man but but the thing is that
the bible also says to be fruitful and
multiply yes within the context and
sanctity of marriage which may be true
but i look at results
and that's the thing like that like when
i go into any church as many of you know
i was just banned on tick tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible